let's talk about walking home for
Christmas what's it all about well it's
about raising money you don't have to
run a marathon you don't have to climb a
mountain you can walk home with your
friends from the pub or you can take the
stroller out and go around the park and
come home go to www.uwec.edu/career of
course this time of you but also
Christmas is quite a hard time for a lot
of people you feel isolated you know if
you're an institution like the Armed
Forces if you're suddenly out of that
and as you say seven people a day and
medically discharged from our armed
forces they often find themselves on
their own with not many people who they
can go and talk to so this is about
raising money to look after them for
their mental health if their physical
well-being and also I hope that that any
veterans out there that are watching
this if they feel that they need to talk
someone please pick up the phone speak
to walking with the wheel do that bring
up help for Heroes ring up anyone and
start talking because that's the first
step about getting over mental about
PTSD for instance you've got to start
talking about it so you know it's a
great opportunity for civilians aren't
myself as you say I'm not gonna run
American and I'm not gonna climb a
balancing but I could stagger home from
the pub in an orderly fashion yes
whatever it is whether it's walking in
your favorite woods and then walking
home we're going to get a Christmas tree
and walking home get some sponsorship
money and and help and help our Burum
our veterans who you know have often put
their lives on the line for us I think
it's only fair that we offer some help
back yeah these are people who've served
their country because you say am-7
discharged every day that's 2451
discharged medically last year you
touched on it a little bit but what
support is there because it's a very
different world outside of the military
and it's sort of like not made a program
about PTSD about four five years ago and
it's a bit of a postcode lottery as to
what kind of support you get with mental
health anyway
particularly if you you're experiencing
PTSD you know you're not necessarily
going to be able to find someone out
there that specializes in the area the
you're suffering from so you know that's
why this charity for me is is this
operation is quite quite important in
this campaign and I'll be carefully
taking part we walked this morning from
Millennium Bridge to the cemetery with
some some people who are at service
personnel who have been helped and it
was a credibly positive experience it
was raining well we had a bit of a laugh
there were civilians like myself
ex-service personnel and we all got on
quite well and it's you know you can be
sitting there having your Christmas
dinner this year with an extra smile on
your face because you know you've helped
someone who was vulnerable and also
someone you probably possibly risk their
lives fee for your liberty for your
safety we seem to be talking about PTSD
more and more last week we were talking
about the veteran who'd gone out on
hunger strike we had a veteran here
sitting where you are talking about the
support or lack of that is available and
when we are expecting these men and
women to go out and fight for their
country we are now relying on charities
to give them their support is that right
sadly yes you know the National Health
Service can only go so far and and there
are you know sadly there are there are
holes there and and and the great
British public as always has never been
sure and coming forward when it comes to
charity but this particularly you know
having been out to Afghan a few times
and seen the kind of sacrifices that
were made not only by service personnel
but also by their families and and the
money that will be raised free walking
home for Christmas will also go to help
them you know as you say Christmas can
be a great time it can also be thing
could be lonely time and it's also when
families get together and things come to
a head and a lot of people who've got
PTSD you know can often the Christmas
can be a kick starter for that and it is
shocking really isn't it when you think
and when you when you talk to homeless
people did a proportion of them are
servicemen because you know they leave
this institution
that is regimented that is organized and
all of a sudden they find themselves on
their own was on the guys I was talking
to you today you know he was involved in
a serious motorcycle accident after it
oh why was it serving but after he got
back from Afghanistan he left the army
he fed himself on his own in virtually
any end he had 15 pence to his name but
through working with healthy Heroes he's
got himself back together again and you
see them light fitter than I am and he's
a fantastic guy and also you could at
bear in mind a lot of people who've
served they have skills hmm and so many
of them are unemployed we need to get
them back to get them back into society
to integrate them back in we have to
help them get jobs
so just for a hundred and fifty pounds
you can get someone get them trained how
to write a CV properly so they can you
know apply for a job yeah again you sort
of feel isn't that the role of the
military and the mo D to support someone
as they make that transition into
civilian life I wonder also whether
public awareness is starting to wane now
that we're not involved in the big
campaigns like Iraq and Afghanistan but
of course and I think everybody that
went out to Afghan knew that was gonna
happen but it's not just gonna help
people who've been Afghans on it's
anyone that's served wherever they may
observe and of course you know it's not
headline news anymore some people have
very short memories often politicians
have very short memories it's not
fashionable
maybe but you know as you say seven
people a day leaving the Armed Forces
most of whom are in need of help and the
only way they probably get their help is
from charity yeah Prince Harry has been
doing a lot of work around this raising
awareness about mental health issues as
well as physical health issues for those
leaving and the army through his work
with the Invictus games and I wonder how
important it is to have high profile
support compared myself to him he's his
way overhead and ahead of me and on that
but he also called for charities to come
together and that's what's great about
this you know yes I was looking with
help for Heroes working together
collaborating to help people that
desperately need it
so if people want to know what they can
do how they can get involved in the
run-up to Christmas
tell us between the 13th of this month -
the 23rd of November at any point go to
WWE home for Christmas you will get a
pack and a wonderful Santa's hat that I
was wearing this morning got a bit damp
had to squeeze a bobble a couple of
times and get as many of your friends as
possible or family members or colleagues
at work and do a walk
does it have to be of any lengths in
particular it can be it can be 10 yards
or a thousand yards it's entirely up to
you